[Música]
eeuu confía en que la otan aceptará como
miembros a finlandia y a suecia al
tiempo que reabrió la embajada
estadounidense en kiel mientras que
rusia expulsar a diplomáticos de francia
italia y españa tenemos información
desde madrid
el gigante del cemento en francia la
compañía la faja enfrentará cargos por
complicidad con crímenes de lesa
humanidad los jueces la acusan de
enviarles 13 millones de euros para los
yihadistas a cambio de que les
permitieran operar en siria en medio de
la guerra
un homenaje a tom cruise ya la secuela
de top gun durante 5 minutos lo
aplaudieron en el festival de cannes
donde se estrena la segunda parte de la
película de
1986 en la riviera francesa recordarán
los logros cinematográficos del actor
tenemos reporte desde allí
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es maría clara calle y es un
gusto estar con ustedes
el presidente de estadounidense joe
biden respaldó a finlandia y suecia para
convertirse en miembros de la otan y
afirmó que confía en que su solicitud
será aceptada especialmente por turquía
que ha sido el único de los países de la
alianza militar que ha rechazado el
ingreso de los países nórdicos mañana
bailén recibirá en washington a su
homólogo finlandés saudí ministo y a la
primera ministra sueca magdalena
adversión esto para discutir sus
solicitudes a la otan otra de las
movidas diplomáticas ocurrió en kiev
después de casi tres meses de haber
cerrado ahora la embajada estadounidense
en ucrania reabrió sus puertas
mientras tanto rusia expulsó
diplomáticos de francia italia y españa
luego de que el mes pasado varios
funcionarios rusos fueron sacados de
dichos países europeos además occidente
acusó a rusia por la muerte de civiles
en busca nuestra corresponsal en madrid
marina colorado nos cuenta más de la
situación
el anuncio de la expulsión de 27
integrantes del personal de la embajada
y consulado español en rusia ha llegado
durante una reunión entre el ministerio
de asuntos exteriores ruso y el
embajador de españa en moscú es la
respuesta asimétrica que en madrid
habían estado esperando desde que el 5
de abril 'españa expulsar a la misma
cantidad de diplomáticos rusos la
expulsión de entonces que afectó al 60%
de la plantilla de la embajada de la
federación rusa en la capital española
fue la materialización del rechazo a la
invasión de ucrania iniciada a finales
de febrero y sobre todo a los posibles
crímenes de guerra cometidos por el
ejército liderado por vladimir putin en
varias ciudades ucranianas como bucha o
boro dianca el embajador de españa en
rusia no se ha visto afectado por esta
decisión respuesta de moscú ya que
españa mantuvo en su puesto al jefe de
la delegación diplomática rusa en madrid
para dejar según el ministerio de
asuntos exteriores de españa jose manuel
alvar es una línea de diálogo abierta
entre ambos países el ministerio de
asuntos exteriores español ha rechazado
esta decisión de rusia que obliga a los
empleados a abandonar el país en una
semana los anuncios de moscú varios
países hostiles como los denomina el
kremlin se dan mientras finlandia y
suecia pretenden unirse a la otan un
proceso que han apoyado todos los países
integrantes del organismo excepto
turquía avanza el primer juicio por
crímenes de guerra en ucrania hoy el
soldado acusado de matar a un civil
desarmado se declaró culpable el
uniformado ruso de 21 años se
enfrentaría a una sentencia a cadena
perpetua por asesinato premeditado
rusia dice que no tiene información del
militar en juicio veamos más en el
siguiente informe
se ha convertido en el primer rostro de
los presuntos crímenes de guerra rusos
vadims y marín de 21 años está acusado
de matar a un hombre desarmado de 62 en
la región de schumi al noreste del país
en febrero apenas unos días después de
que comenzara la invasión él y otros
cuatro soldados supuestamente robaron un
vehículo y estaban huyendo cuando se
encontraron con el hombre y lo mataron
para evitar ser denunciados la fiscal
superior de ucrania dice que el juicio
que tienen lugar en medio del conflicto
en curso pretende entregar un mensaje
con este primer juicio estamos enviando
una señal clara de todos los autores
todas las personas que ordenaron o
ayudaron a cometer crímenes en ucrania
no podrán evitar su responsabilidad
también están en marcha varias
investigaciones internacionales con la
participación de la onu y la corte penal
internacional
muchas se centran en el suburbio de
busca en kiev donde se encontraron los
cadáveres de cientos de civiles tras la
retirada de las tropas rusas a
principios de abril mientras tanto los
fiscales ucranianos avanzan en la
investigación de más de 11.000 casos y
se espera que otros dos también se
desarrollen rápidamente un soldado ruso
será juzgado en ausencia por violación y
asesinato mientras que el juicio contra
dos soldados acusados de disparar
cohetes contra civiles en la región
nororiental de jarquín comenzará el
jueves y el mariupol crece el número de
soldados ucranianos que salieron de la
planta a soft al el ministerio de
defensa ruso afirmó que hoy
694 combatientes se rindieron con lo que
ya van
959 en poder de las tropas de moscú
quien no habla de rendiciones sino que
sostiene que sus militares fueron
evacuados de negociar un intercambio de
prisioneros se desconoce cuántas
personas siguen dentro de la acería
aunque líderes separatistas pro rusos
afirman que varios de los comandantes
ucranianos siguen luchando desde la
planta
en noticias de francia a un tribunal de
apelación de parís confirmó que la faja
el gigante del cemento francés que luego
se fusionó con el simm debe enfrentar
cargos de complicidad en crímenes contra
la humanidad acusar a la empresa de
supuestos sobornos al autodenominado
estado islámico y otros grupos
yihadistas durante la guerra en siria
anteriormente de la fach ya había sido
acusada por ese crimen pero en una
apelación logró retirar el cargo ahora
vuelve a enfrentar la investigación más
delicada
una decisión aclamada por grupos de
derechos humanos un tribunal de
apelación de parís confirmó que la farsa
debería recibir cargos de complicidad en
crímenes contra la humanidad la primera
empresa francesa en encarar tales cargos
a inicios de 2012 al conflicto sirio se
intensificó en el norte del país y
muchas empresas francesas decidieron
cerrar pero no las farc que quiso
mantener su cementera funcionando
consciente del peligro la compañía
francesa estableció contacto con varios
grupos armados que operaban en la zona
incluido el autodenominado estado
islámico los jueces acusan a las farc de
desviar al menos 13 millones de euros a
yihadistas a cambio de libertad de
movimiento para su personal y
equipamiento descubierto por un grupo de
periodistas en verano de 2016 la
investigación provocó un gran escándalo
ese mismo año el ministro de economía
francés abrió una investigación
preliminar contra la compañía en abril
de 2017 el escándalo forzó la dimisión
del director eric olson dos veces más
tarde el fiscal público de parís comenzó
una investigación por supuesta
financiación del terrorismo ocho
ejecutivos fueron investigados un año
más tarde la farsa fue imputada por
múltiples cargos que incluyen
complicidad con crímenes contra la
humanidad financiación de terrorismo
está en peligro de vidas de terceros y
violación de un embargo comercial la
compañía apeló y ganó en parte a finales
de 2019 el tribunal de apelaciones de
parís abandonó al cargo de crímenes
contra la humanidad pero mantuvo los
demás la nulidad fue apelada a su vez
por dos ongs la farsa admitió que pagó
intermediarios para negociar con grupos
armados pero asegura que desconocía las
conexiones de estos grupos con el
terrorismo en 2021 la corte suprema de
francia invalidó la decisión de cancelar
los cargos de complicidad en crímenes
contra la humanidad hoy ha resurgido el
debate un tribunal de apelaciones de
parís confirmó que la farce debe
enfrentar los cargos más graves el
gigante del cemento que cambió su nombre
a olsen tras su fusión en 2015 con el
grupo suizo discute las acusaciones y se
prepara para apelar el caso una vez más
luego si las jugadoras de las elecciones
de fútbol de estados unidos se unieron y
alcanzaron un acuerdo con su federación
la ues soccer ahora tanto las mujeres
como los hombres no sólo tendrán el
mismo salario sino que además recibirán
los mismos premios y bonificaciones
así se da por terminada la demanda de
2016 por discriminación laboral e
interpusieron algunas de las jugadoras
ellas alegaban que a pesar de haber
ganado mundiales y cuatro medallas de
oro olímpicas les pagaban menos que a la
selección masculina los pactos se
extenderán hasta 2028
en américa aumentaron un 27% los nuevos
contagios por kobe 19 la semana pasada
así lo reveló la organización
panamericana de salud en el último mes
la pandemia se ha propagado de manera
constante en el continente por lo que
las hospitalizaciones crecieron en 18
países y centroamérica fue la región
donde más incrementaron los casos con un
80% más de positivos que en la medición
anterior ante este panorama la ope ese
alerta que la situación puede empeorar
la semana pasada nuestra región registró
más de 900 18.000 casos lo cual
representa un aumento del 27,2 por
ciento en comparación con la semana
anterior se registraron más de 3500
muestres las hospitalizaciones por kobe
19 aumentaron en 18 países y las
admisiones a unidades de cuidados
intensivos
aumentaron en 13 países y territorios la
organización metereológica mundial
publicó un informe en el que advierte
sobre el agravamiento de la crisis clima
esta organización alertó y su informe de
2021 que los océanos alcanzaron máximos
de calentamiento y acidificación
asimismo señaló que los niveles de
dióxido de carbono y de metano en la
atmósfera superaron los del año anterior
el reporte también acusa que los últimos
siete años han sido los más calurosos de
los que se tiene constancia hasta ahora
antes de esto también hoy se conoció que
las muertes por el aire contaminado
aumentaron un 7% entre 2015 y 2019 según
reveló un estudio de la alianza global
en salud y polución más detalles en el
siguiente reporte en los cielos de las
grandes ciudades se ve la lo gris de la
polución la contaminación atmosférica
causada por las actividades humanas es
cada vez más perjudicial para la salud
según un estudio publicado en la revista
the lancet planetary health las muertes
relacionadas a la contaminación del aire
aumentaron un 7% entre 2015 y 2019 un
fenómeno que causa la muerte de 9
millones de personas al año y que sigue
estando poco identificado según los
autores del estudio
la contaminación es un factor de riesgo
de muerte como muchos otros cuando se
observa que contribuye a la
contaminación se trata principalmente de
enfermedades no transmisibles que
figuran como causa real de muerte en el
certificado de defunción casi nunca
verás la contaminación como causa de
muerte
según el estudio el 75% de estas muertes
están causadas directamente por la
contaminación atmosférica pero las
muertes por exposición a sustancias
químicas y metales pesados también han
aumentado un 66% desde el año 2000 se
trata de un fenómeno que afecta
principalmente a los países pobres y en
desarrollo
cuando estos países industrializados se
produce también un fenómeno de
urbanización cada vez más personas se
trasladan a las zonas donde hay
contaminación y al mismo tiempo hay un
envejecimiento de la población todas
estas cosas se combinan y aumentan la
carga de estas poblaciones
chad la república centroafricana y
nigeria son algunos de los países que
registran la mayor tasa de mortalidad
por la contaminación atmosférica
y pasamos a noticias del cine en la
jornada de hoy el festival de cannes le
rindió un homenaje al actor tom cruise y
a la secuela de su histórica película
top gun y es que en la riviera francesa
se estrenó este miércoles el filme top
gun madrid' que se pospuso desde 2019
por la pandemia el actor recibió una
ovación de pie durante 5 minutos y
además la fuerza aérea francesa hizo un
desfile en los cielos
mariah calor y maría carolina piña la
enviada especial de rf y nuestra cadena
aliada nos cuenta los detalles de la
ceremonia de apertura
glamour zombies y la actualidad
internacional se dieron cita en la
inauguración del festival de cannes
el festival de cine más grande del mundo
se inauguró en el pequeño balneario de
cannes como siempre con una lluvia de
estrellas del séptimo arte mundial que
desfilaron por la alfombra roja y
posaron para los fotógrafos
[Música]
te abrió así la edición número 75 del
festival de cannes cita que no cerró los
ojos ante la guerra en ucrania y
permitió que el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski tomará la palabra
para hablar del poder del cine y
denunciar una vez más la invasión rusa a
su país
la velada concluyó con la proyección
fuera de la competencia de la cinta
final coach del francés michel
hazanavicius cinta hilarante que cuenta
el rodaje de una película de zombies de
tercera categoría
realizar su firme el hecho de haber
filmado esta película luego de la
pandemia y de reírnos como niños con
escenas o chistes tontos ligeros nos
permitió liberar toda esta tensión y nos
hizo mucho bien a todos y quizás la
gente tiene sed de comedia estoy muy
feliz de traer un poco de felicidad
estamos viviendo momentos muy difíciles
pero no podemos dejar de reír con esta
cosa yo veo muy poco vaina el coche es
la versión francesa hay una cinta
japonesa de muertos vivientes pero
detrás de la profusión de sangre y de
decapitaciones es también una carta de
amor al cine y al caótico complicado y
apasionado oficio de hacer películas
[Música]
y con estas imágenes de cannes nos
despedimos por ahora pero los invitamos
a que sigan conectados con france24 para
más información
[Música]